we reserved some of our deepest scorn
for couples who stay together out of
compromise those who are making a show
of unanimity but whom we know are deep
down not fully happy maybe they're
primarily together because of the
children maybe they're sticking around
because they're scared of being lonely
or maybe they're just worried that
anyone else they found wouldn't be much
better these seem like disgraceful
motives to be with anyone disgraceful on
account of a background belief that
circulates powerfully through the
collective modern psyche the idea that
anyone who puts their mind and will
sufficiently to it doesn't have to
compromise in love that there are pain
free profoundly fulfilling options
available for all of us and the only
things that could stand in the way of
discovering them could be laziness or
cowardice flaws of character that
deserve no particular sympathy or
forgiveness are high romantic
expectations have made us notably
impatient around and censorious about
those who can't attain them but imagine
if we were to tweak the premise of the
argument a little and for a moment probe
at the notion that there really might be
a pain free an entirely fulfilling
option available for all of us at all
times
what if our choices were in many
contexts in fact often rather more
limited than Romanticism proposes maybe
there aren't as many admirable
unattached people in our vicinity as
there might be maybe we lack the charm
the personality the career the
confidence or the looks ever to attract
the ones that do exist
maybe time is running out or maybe our
children really would take it extremely
badly if we dynamited the family for the
sake of better sex and greater cheer
elsewhere at the same time maybe the
current situation while clearly a
compromise is not without its virtues a
partner may be only half right quite
often maddening and properly
disappointing in certain areas but
humbling ly still more satisfying than
being alone having
children to bring up together may be
worth it even with a co-parent about
whom one has a long only semi-private
list of reservations a few cuddles and
occasional moments of coziness may
retain a small decisive edge over
conclusive abandonment interspersed with
humiliating dates the capacity to
compromise is not always the weakness
it's described as being it can involve a
mature realistic admission that there
may in certain situations simply be no
ideal options and conversely an
inability to compromise doesn't always
have to be the courageous and visionary
position it's held to be by our
impatient and perfectionist ideology it
may just be a slightly rigid proud and
cruel delusion mocking people who
compromise is of course emotionally very
handy it localizes a problem that it's
normal to want to disavow it pins to a
few scapegoat couples what we are all
terrified about in our relationships but
a degree of sadness may just be an
intrinsic and unavoidable part of them
why the society would be careful never
to stigmatize the act of compromise it's
painful enough to have to compromise
it's even more painful to have to hate
oneself for having done so we should
rehabilitate and occasionally honor the
ability to put up with a flawed fellow
human being to nurse our sadness without
falling into rage or despair to
reconcile ourselves to our damaged
appearance and character and to accept
that there may be no better way for us
to live but partly in pain and longing
given who we are and what the world can
provide couples who compromise may in
reality not be the enemies of love they
may be at the vanguard of understanding
what lasting relationships truly demand
did you know that the School of Life is
actually a place ten places in fact camp
all over the world from Melbourne to
London Taipei to Istanbul with classes
and books and lots more please click on
the link below to explore more